indeed representing brooklyn well irina
this game seemed to be going pretty
solidly she didn't seem to be aggressing
but that time was ticking down very
quickly were you aware or thinking about
the fact that she was taking so long in
the game in a position that looks like a
position yeah i think of course the
the time factor was the main thing in
this game and it was definitely
something that i was aware of from the
very beginning i remember like okay i
have a 20 minute advantage and i have a
30 minute advantage a 40 minute and you
know 40 minutes is very comfortable so i
mean i knew that that the time was um
was going to decide the game most likely
yeah she collapsed pretty quickly in
fact when she took on e5 it looked like
you were very confident right at this
moment when she took on e5 and allowed
you to be able to just storm her king
position yeah you know i'll tell you
what was the like kind of the hardest
moments in the game for me just a few
moves before this um
uh after rugby
we're going to put it on screen uh pull
it up we'll get yesterday yeah after 21
uh rook d3
and
you know i had been going for this
position i mean okay i thought maybe
white would play f3 uh but rook d3 i
think is a better move
there's no real reason to chase my
bishop away because actually it wants to
go back to e6 right so she played rook
d3 and you know my general vision for
this position was like i was going to
castle play c5 c4 and just attack and i
thought with my light squared bishop
it wouldn't be easy for white to
blockade the queen side and then i
realized that she has if i castle she
has this move queen g5
and i was like wow what a bummer this
move is because i don't really want to
go into the end game i can't play f6 i
thought about all the different queen
moves that i have but they involve
giving up the f6 square to white's queen
yeah like queen c5 queen f6 and so for
me this was like actually quite a
critical moment because if i let white
play queen g5 i might just lose you know
at least uh i mean i'm sure i'll have a
decent position i mean i can always
figure out something to do but in terms
of having the playing initiative i
wouldn't have that so the idea of bishop
e6 this move i was quite happy with
is that on one hand i'm preparing the
move c5 so there's no rook d5
and on the other hand queen g5 is not as
big of a problem because i haven't even
castled yet so i could actually just
play like c5 here
so i mean that was my thinking at least
um perhaps you know white can go into
those end games and i actually was
expecting the end game to happen i mean
when she took my pawn i was quite happy
when she took the pawn on e5 a few moves
later yeah i was expecting the queen
trade of course um here i don't know i
mean i felt my position was comfortable
of course i'm you know kind of better
but is it enough to win well i mean
there would still be a lot of work to do
but instead she took the pawn and
allowed a searing attack after f6 yeah i
was happy to get that
um king to f7 to connect my rooks and uh
just to get those pawns rolling
the game ended abruptly quickly after
that a big win for you so soon in the
competition we know uh this is your
attempt at going for your ninth
title
obviously can't uh start any better than
winning with the black pieces yeah i'm
happy i mean you have to kind of get
into the tournament it's really
important you know i haven't played in a
long time um haven't played over the
board chess since the 2020 karen's cup
so i think you know the first few rounds
you're just kind of
warming up you know and it's nice when
you can have a game that it doesn't get
too stressful you manage your time well
i think i um chose the opening while a
lot a lot of of course you know a lot of
um this stuff you know no one can really
see but like those opening choices in
the beginning are quite important you
know and there's some improvisation
taking place um
uh you know when your opponent surprises
you a bit and then you try to surprise
them back so i feel like that worked out
so yeah i'm pretty happy all right well
thanks so much for joining us and good
luck tomorrow thank you
well done